ok
[Musica]
che cosa regala la vita per natale
ho una bambola
crea la tua bambola
sì ma questo è un ordine come oggi ha
accettato tutto accesso alla casa
mi piace andare in commissione della
casa
acconsente a fornire una lacrima una
ciocca di capelli
ok inserisce una foto tieni da perché va
bene
inserisci qui i dettagli ok
[Musica]
wow poi viene effettuato con successo
ho finito lo sa che devo andare subito a
prenderla degli altri e dove ci pare qui
hai mangiato nuovamente tutti planisfero
no che cosa devo pensare
la casa vuota 20 è stato berlino berlino
berlino berlino cosa hai fatto
ganeto questi sono puliti berlino e
della loro detto che è stato lui cosa
sta minacciando computer niente o meglio
niente di cui tutti gli possa
preoccupare io che vado a controllare ma
c'è bisogno davvero credimi ordini in
elaborazione che cosa ordinato questa
volta
fornire una ciocca di capelli fornire
una lacrima vitale che cosa hai
combinato questa volta niente io ho solo
cercato tutte le cose non mi venivano
proposti da dicendosi io accetto che
cosa hai accettato che sito è questo
niente sono stato solo levava trascura
di internet ordinando una bambola ho
mangiato gran kate
poi ho mangiato un po anche il carciofo
lato non vedi che c'è qualcosa di strano
chiede una ciocca di capelli e una
lacrima è stato stranissimo
effettivamente messo così effettivamente
forse caso di cancellarlo in funzione
piace la cancella
ma guarda stanno cercando di annullare
l'ordine non si cancella premi questo
non è più cancellabile stanno ancora
provando ad annullare l'ordine non mi
stanno prendendo sul serio non prendono
sul serio il mio lavoro la mia arte
cancellati vuol dire è un ordine 300 si
[Musica]
è sentito era sopra possiamo controllare
mini berlino andiamo
contro le camere o altro
sì
questo è successo su caduti per adesso
mi ha fatto rumore
che strano come ho fatto a credere da
sole queste cose colpo di vento forse
dalla finestra finestra è chiusa perché
io a mettere è strano berlino sei stato
tu eri con noi
[Risate]
[Musica]
berlino sei stato tu cosa siano riina è
successo qualcosa qua che marino sia
saltato di dirci qualcosa si comporta in
maniera davvero strana un vino
ho notato che c'è qualcosa di strano in
questa stanza forse ma forse forse no
forse era giusto il scommetto che stanno
impazzendo sento strani lo faccio è
arrivato alle orecchie merlino di stato
tu
[Musica]
se qualcuno dentro l'armadio
se nessuno scusi signor armadio
[Musica]
che cos'è poi credo sia per la pioggia
di fulmini e magari un campo
elettromagnetico che l'ho detto che c'è
qualcosa di strano in questa casa ed è
tutto iniziato da quando hai fatto
quello strano ordine
senti questi rumori si
da dove provengono da sopra a sotto
capisco che ci sarà un grande evento che
quest'anno con il probabile mai perso
andiamo giù grida ok
mi manca solo una ciocca di capelli una
lacrima ma sai io a prenderti le ciocche
di capelli una lacrima così potrò
finalmente completare la mia bambola
perfetta visto che non riusciamo ad
annullare l'ordine dobbiamo spegnere
mobilità si va bene proviamo
bene bene bene bene bene che è arrivato
il momento di andare a prendere quello
che mi serve per completare la mia
creazione la ciocca di capelli una
lacrima
che cosa possono contare
sicuramente corte roma è sì anche tu
potresti servirmi tu tu vieni con me
e arrivato il momento di andare
[Musica]